Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收听各系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼错，所以你只需要报个假名，用你的咖啡馆名字，茱莉亚。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等一下。茱莉亚到底喜欢哪种意式浓缩咖啡？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 意式浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些纠结了，因为你在家里就能自己做意式浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. The truth is rarely pure and never simple. Modern life would be very tedious if it were either. And modern literature, a complete impossibility. That wouldn't be at all a bad thing. Literary criticism is not your forte, my dear fellow. Don't try it. You should leave that to people who haven't been at a university. They do it so well in the daily papers. What you really are is a Bunburyist. I was quite right in saying you were a Bunburyist. You
即刻前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。真相纯粹之时绝少，简单之时绝无。如果现代生活非要二者居其一，那将变得极其乏味；而现代文学则会彻底成为不可能。那其实也不是什么坏事。文学批评可不是你的强项，我的好朋友。别尝试了。你应该把这留给那些没上过大学的人。他们在日报上写得可真好。你真正称得上是一个班伯里主义者（Bunburyist）。我说你是个班伯里主义者，一点也没错。你
are one of the most advanced Bunburyists I know. Tom, what on earth do you mean? You have invented, Dominic, a very useful younger brother called Ernest, in order that you may be able to come up to town as often as you like. I have invented an invaluable permanent invalid called Bunbury, in order that I may be able to go down into the country whenever I choose. Bunbury is perfectly invaluable. If it wasn't for Bunbury's extraordinary bad health, for instance, I wouldn't be able to dine with you at Willis's tonight,
是我所知道的最先进的班伯里主义者之一。汤姆，你到底是什么意思？多米尼克，你虚构了一个非常能干的弟弟，名叫欧内斯特（Ernest），这样你就可以随时随地随心所欲地进城了。我虚构了一个无可挑剔、长期病弱的家伙叫班伯里（Bunbury），这样我只要一想去乡下就能随时去了。班伯里简直太不可或缺了。比方说，要不是班伯里那异乎寻常的糟糕健康状况，我今晚就没法陪你在威利斯餐厅（Willis's）共进晚餐了，
for I have been really engaged to Aunt Augusta for more than a week. So that was The Importance of Being Earnest by Oscar Wilde. I think we can safely describe that as one of the ripest performances that we've heard for a long time in the rest of its history. Tom, we're out here in the sunshine in Washington, D.C. We are. Annoying Americans with your... Affected. Yeah.
因为我其实在一個多星期前就已经答应奥古斯塔阿姨了。以上就是奥斯卡·王尔德的《不可儿戏》（The Importance of Being Earnest）。我想我们可以毫不夸张地将其描述为我们在《历史的余烬》中听过的最成熟的表演之一。汤姆，我们现在身处华盛顿特区灿烂的阳光下。确实如此。用你那……矫揉造作的……去惹恼美国人。对。
Affected, indeed. Affected. Affected tones. So if you hear dogs... Helicopters. You know that's because we're out here in Washington. And Tom, our subject today, it's a cracking subject, isn't it? The Trials of Oscar Wilde.
确实是矫揉造作。矫揉造作。矫揉造作的腔调。所以，如果你听到狗叫…… 直升机声。你知道那是因为我们在华盛顿。汤姆，我们今天的主题，真是一个绝佳的主题，不是吗？王尔德的审判（The Trials of Oscar Wilde）。
The Trials of Oscar Wilde. And we began with Importance Being Earnest, which is his most famous play, gloriously funny play. Jack Worthing, Algernon Moncrief, two kind of young gentlemen about town in London. Algernon Moncrief's terrifying aunt Augusta, is lady bracknell as in a hundberg all that kind of i wondered how long it would take yeah well we get it straight in and i have a particular fondness for that play because it inspired the very first piece of writing for which i got paid which was a play called the importance of being frank which reworked the plot of the importance of being earnest to tell the story of oscar wilde himself so in that play, Jack Worthing became Oscar Wilde,
王尔德的审判。我们以《不可儿戏》开场，这是他最著名的戏剧，一部光彩夺目、妙趣横生的喜剧。杰克·沃辛（Jack Worthing）、阿尔杰农·蒙克利夫（Algernon Moncrief），伦敦城里两位风流倜傥的年轻绅士。阿尔杰农·蒙克利夫那可怕的奥古斯塔阿姨，也就是布拉克内尔夫人（Lady Bracknell），就像在亨堡（hundberg）一样，诸如此类。我还在想这会持续多久呢。是的，我们言归正传。我对这部戏剧有着特殊的喜爱，因为它启发了我获得第一笔稿费的作品，那是一部名为《坦率的重要性》（The Importance of Being Frank）的戏剧，它重构了《不可儿戏》的剧情，讲述了奥斯卡·王尔德自己的故事。所以在那个剧里，杰克·沃辛变成了奥斯卡·王尔德，
Algernon Moncrief became Bosie, Lord Alfred Douglas. You are an excellent Bosie, Tom. Thank you very much. Who was Wilde's lover. And Aunt Augusta, Lady Bracknell, became the Marquess of Queensbrook. Oh, very good. Who was Bosie's father and who was so furious about the affair that wild and douglas were having that he kind of went around london accusing wild of being a somdomite it's a misspelled opposing
阿尔杰农·蒙克利夫变成了波西（Bosie），即阿尔弗雷德·道格拉斯勋爵（Lord Alfred Douglas）。你是个极好的波西，汤姆。非常感谢。他曾是王尔德的情人。而奥古斯塔阿姨，布拉克内尔夫人，则变成了昆斯伯里侯爵（Marquess of Queensberry）。哦，太棒了。他是波西的父亲，对王尔德和道格拉斯之间的私情极为愤怒，以至于他在伦敦到处指控王尔德是个鸡奸者（somdomite）。这是一个拼写错误的“鸡奸者”
somdomite yes and wild then charged him with libel yeah came to court the evidence that queensberry rustled up was so devastating for wild's case that he withdrew the libel accusation and then he wild in turn got arrested there were two trials and he ended up being sent to prison he did it's the story isn't it it's the it's the great 19th century martyrdom story i suppose certainly that's how it's perceived now there was the film with stephen fry as oscar wilde and oscar wilde is now i would say seen across the western world as this great martyr in the course of gay rights isn't he i mean that's pretty much how he's seen as the sacrificial victim destroyed by a repressive old-fashioned puritanical establishment which as we will see in these episodes, is actually not quite right.
是的，“somdomite”。王尔德随后起诉他诽谤。是的，闹到了法庭上。昆斯伯里搜集到的证据对王尔德的案子具有毁灭性的打击，以至于他撤回了诽谤指控，接着，王尔德反过来被捕了。经历了两次审判，他最终被判入狱。确实如此。这就是那个故事，不是吗？它大概是19世纪最伟大的殉道故事了。当然，现在人们也是这么看的。曾经有过一部由斯蒂芬·弗雷（Stephen Fry）饰演奥斯卡·王尔德的电影，如今在整个西方世界，奥斯卡·王尔德可以说被视为同性恋权利运动中的一位伟大殉道者，不是吗？我的意思是，差不多就是被看作这样一个牺牲品：被一个压抑的、老派的、清教徒式的体制所摧毁。但正如我们将在这些剧集里看到的，其实并非完全如此。
The story is much more interesting and more complicated, isn't it? So, you criticise me for saying things that are always more complicated than they seem. Well, Dominic, yes. As Algernon said in the passage in Importance Being Earnest we just opened with, the truth is rarely pure and never simple. Very good. And in this case, it's absolutely true so tom oscar wilde born in dublin in 1854 the son of an ireland's leading ophthalmologist and lady wilde so that's sir william his father and lady wilde
这个故事要有趣得多，也复杂得多，不是吗？所以，你批评我说事情总是比看上去更复杂。好吧，多米尼克，是的。正如阿尔杰农在我们刚才开场的《不可儿戏》片段中所说的那样：“真相纯粹之时绝少，简单之时绝无。”说得极是。而在本案中，这绝对是真的。所以，汤姆，奥斯卡·王尔德于1854年出生于都柏林，是爱尔兰顶尖眼科医生和王尔德夫人的儿子——也就是他的父亲威廉爵士（Sir William），而王尔德夫人
was a nationalist poet under the pen name speranza so give us a sense for those people not massively familiar with him and his work why he mattered in the late 19th century and what he you know why do we remember him why was he such a big figure so he's intellectually very brilliant he takes degrees at trinity college dublin which is the of course the protestant university in dublin that we were talking about um only a couple of weeks ago uh he then goes to ox, does classics, wins all kinds of prizes there. And he leaves and becomes a kind of, he sets himself up really as a kind of professional East seat. Yes. To the degree that Gilbert and Sullivan write an opera about him. And they then take it to America and Wilde goes to America with the opera. And he kind of famously arrives wearing all kinds of
是一位以笔名“斯佩兰扎”（Speranza）闻名的民族主义诗人。那么，对于那些对王尔德及其作品不太熟悉的人，请给我们讲讲他在19世纪末为什么如此重要，以及他——你知道的，我们为什么纪念他？他为什么是个如此重要的人物？他才华横溢，在都柏林三一学院（Trinity College Dublin）获得学位——当然就是我们几周前讨论过的都柏林那所新教大学。嗯，他随后去牛津大学学习古典学，并在那里赢得了各种奖项。他毕业后成为了一种……他实际上把自己包装成了一种职业唯美主义者。是的。甚至到了吉尔伯特和沙利文（Gilbert and Sullivan）为他写了一部歌剧的地步。然后他们把歌剧带到了美国，王尔德也带着这部歌剧去了美国。据说他到达时身穿各种
incredible clothing and is asked, you know, does he have anything to declare? And says, I have only my genius to declare. Which is what you said to the immigration official yesterday. Yes, and was then all the way. Do you know what I said to the immigration official? Said to me, which one are you? Because we'd had to explain who we were. He said to me, which one are you in the partnership?
不可思议的服装，当被问及“你有什么要申报的吗？”时，他回答：“我唯有才华可以申报。”这跟你昨天对移民官员说的话一模一样。是的，当时一路都是这样。你知道我对移民官员说了什么吗？他问我：“你们俩谁跟谁？”因为我们得解释我们是谁。他问我：“你们搭档里谁是哪个？”
You know, are you his boss or is he yours? And I said, oh, well, I'm not his boss. He said, well, which one are you? I said, I'm the funny one and the one who knows about history he found that very entertaining did he so you declared your genius dominic exactly very nice exactly mr williams just shout out to mr officer williams of the u.s border force so wild did not need a straight man as i do so he just came on his own he kind of became kind of international star for being witty, for being funny, for incredible kind of intellectual brilliance. And his works, you really rate his
“你知道的，你是他的老板还是他是你的老板？”我说：“哦，我不是他的老板。”他说：“那你们俩谁是谁？”我说：“我是负责搞笑的那个，也是懂历史的那个。”他觉得这非常有趣，是吧？所以你申报了你的才华，多米尼克。完全正确，非常好，完全正确。威廉先生，向美国边境执法局的威廉警官致敬。所以王尔德不需要一个捧哏的，不像我。他自己就去了。他凭借自己的机智、风趣以及不可思议的才华，成为了某种国际巨星。他的作品——你对他的作品评价极高。
works. You know, it's not just about the persona. You think what he produced were works of tremendous literary elegance. Yes. So he comes back to Britain. He amazingly, he becomes the editor of the Ladies magazine and he turns it into a kind of proto spare rib. So he's back to Britain. Amazingly, he becomes the editor of the Ladies magazine and he turns it into a kind of proto spare rib. So he's very kind of progressive, very kind of feminist. And then he gets bored of doing that. And he, from basically from kind of 1890 onwards, he embarks on kind of one of the great sequences of literary successes in British cultural history. So he produces a novel, Dorian Gray, which will feature in the story of The Trials, because it's about a beautiful young man who is up to all kinds of sinister things that Wilde doesn't specify in the novel. And he has a picture
你知道的，这不仅仅关乎他的个人魅力。你认为他创作的作品具有极高的文学优雅度。是的。所以他回到英国。令人惊叹的是，他成为了某女性杂志的主编，并把它变成了一种雏形版的《Spare Rib》（注：英国早期女权主义杂志）。所以他回到英国。令人惊叹的是，他成为了某女性杂志的主编，并把它变成了一种雏形版的《Spare Rib》。所以他思想非常前卫，非常倾向于女权主义。然后他厌倦了这份工作。基本上从1890年左右开始，他开启了英国文化史上最伟大的一系列文学成就之旅。他创作了一部小说《道格拉斯·格雷的画像》（Dorian Gray）——这将在“审判”的故事中占据重要地位，因为它讲述了一个美丽年轻男子背地里干了各种见不得人的勾当，而王尔德在小说中并没有明说。他在阁楼里藏了一张画，
up in the attic, which all the kind of depravity and evil that he's doing is reflected in the painting. Dorian Gray maintains his beauty throughout. He writes a famous tragedy, Salome. He writes a series of brilliantly sophisticated and witty essays. And he writes a series of comedies. Lady Windermere's fan, A Woman of No Importance, and the most famous one of all, The Importance of Being Earnest, which is probably the lightest funniest freshest comedy in english i would say but let's get into the other side of wild's life so well or is it really another side because of course it's reflected
他所做的种种堕落和邪恶都反映在那幅画上。而道雷·格雷本人则始终保持着他的美貌。他写了一部著名的悲剧《莎乐美》（Salome）。他写了一系列极其精致、机智的散文。他还写了一系列喜剧：《温德米尔夫人的扇子》（Lady Windermere's Fan）、《无足轻重的女人》（A Woman of No Importance），以及其中最著名的一部——《不可儿戏》，这可能是英语中最轻松、最滑稽、最新鲜的喜剧了，我要这么说。但让我们深入探讨王尔德生活的另一面……或者说，这真的是另一面吗？因为这当然反映在他的作品中。
in his writings so obviously because this episode and the next episode are about his trials there's going to be a lot of sex so this probably isn't one for the kind of five and six year old listeners but the interesting thing about wild i discovered from matthew sturgis's biography so at university and as a very young man he's actually sexually very abstemious there's actually no hint of people say of him his friends say of him he's very prim yeah they talk of his purely refinement of nature one of them calls him one of the purest-minded men that could be met with. And actually, you know, even as he's establishing his reputation as an East Thete, there is no hint of scandal. And he marries Constance Holland.
显然，因为这一集和下一集讲的是他的审判，所以会涉及很多关于性的内容，因此这可能不太适合五六岁的听众。但我从马修·斯特吉斯（Matthew Sturgis）的传记中发现关于王尔德最有趣的一点是：他在大学期间以及非常年轻的时候，在性方面其实非常克制。实际上没有任何迹象表明——人们说他，他的朋友说他——他非常古板。是的，他们谈到他纯洁的本性。其中一人称他为“所能遇到的思想最纯洁的人之一”。事实上，你知道的，甚至在他确立自己作为唯美主义者的声誉时，也没有任何丑闻的迹象。他与康斯坦斯·霍兰（Constance Holland）结了婚。
Constance Holland, exactly. No relation. And they have two children. But the turning point seems to be, so in 1886, so just at the point where he's about to embark on this period of extraordinary literary output, you know, the high point of his genius, as it were. He meets a 17-year-old, I mean, we would say a boy or a young man called Robbie Ross, who is at a grammar school. He's preparing for Cambridge. And he is...
康斯坦斯·霍兰，完全正确。两人毫无亲属关系。他们有两个孩子。但转折点似乎是——在1886年，也就是他即将开启这段非凡文学创作期（可以说他才华的巅峰期）的节点上。他遇到了一位17岁的年轻人——我的意思是，我们会说是一个男孩或年轻人，名叫罗比·罗斯（Robbie Ross），当时他正在文法学校就读，正准备考入剑桥大学。他是一个……
Absolutely proud. Exactly. He is what we would now call gay he's completely comfortable with it he's admitted that side of his nature to himself and as far as we can tell he seduces the old much older oscar he introduces him to this side of his nature yeah and and wild discovers he really enjoys it and i think he enjoys it on a physical level but i think he enjoys it also on an emotional level because if you think of the plot of dorian gray the idea of secrets and kind of a sense of elevated knowledge amplifying your status is something that he really enjoys and the great theme of wild's writing really is the fact that life is always paradox and yeah and that it's impossible to pin a person down if you can pin a person down then that person is basically dead so he's always
绝对毫不掩饰。没错。他就是我们现在所说的同性恋。他对此完全泰然处之，他在内心承认了自己本性的这一面。据我们所知，是他诱惑了这位年长得多的奥斯卡，他把王尔德引向了自己本性的这一面。是的。而王尔德发现自己真的很享受这种感觉。我想他在生理层面上很享受，但我认为他在情感上也同样享受。因为如果你想想《道格拉斯·格雷》的剧情，那种充满秘密以及通过一种高阶知识来放大你社会地位的想法，正是他非常热衷的东西。而王尔德作品的伟大主题，实际上就是生活永远充满了悖论，
looking for ways to kind of complicate who he is and what his relationship is to his writings and to his kind of, you know, the world in which he's situated. And I think that he had studied classics at Oxford and he identifies very, very strongly with the notion that we talked about actually in our previous episode about Hadrian Antinous, the idea that the Greeks had an elevated understanding of what sexuality could be and that this was focused on same-sex relationships and so he comes to identify this i mean he rapidly becomes very very promiscuous and he seems to have identified this with the kind of cultural superiority that he had obtained by studying ancient greek yeah he thinks he's in
并且，你不可能把一个人彻底定性；如果你能把一个人彻底定性，那么这个人基本上也就“死”了。所以他总是在寻找各种方式来让自己的身份，以及他与自己作品、与他所处的那个世界之间的关系变得更加复杂。我认为他在牛津大学研究过古典学，并且非常非常强烈地认同我们在上一集讨论过的哈德良与安提诺乌斯（Hadrian and Antinous）的概念——希腊人对性能够达到何种高度有着深刻的理解，而这种理解聚焦于同性关系。于是他开始认同这一点——我的意思是，他很快变得非常非常放纵，而且他似乎将这一点与他通过研究古希腊文化而获得的某种文化优越感等同起来。是的，他认为自己传承了希腊人的传统。
the tradition of the greeks there's a kind of platonic ideal of love which is represented by the love of two men he thinks that shakespeare yes he looks into shakespeare michelangelo marlo it's not just that he physically enjoys it as you say it's that it appeals it elevates yes it elevates him exactly now the interesting thing is that this is 1886 one year earlier there had been a change in the law so since 1533 the buggery act passed under emily the eighth had made sodomy the detestable and abominable vice of buggery as it was called and the act had made it a capital crime obviously by the mid-19th century people are no longer being executed for it. They're being sent to prison. But in 1885, and it's a very complicated story, so we'll just give a kind
存在着一种柏拉图式的爱之理想，由两个男人的爱所代表。他认为莎士比亚——是的，他研究莎士比亚、米开朗基罗、马洛。这不仅仅是他身体上的享受，正如你所说，而是这种观念吸引了他，升华了他——是的，这升华了他，完全正确。现在有趣的是，这是1886年。就在一年之前，法律刚刚发生了修改。自1533年亨利八世通过《鸡奸法》（Bugery Act）以来，鸡奸已被定为“令人发指和可恶的鸡奸罪”（正如当时所称），该法将其定为死刑罪。当然，到了19世纪中叶，人们不再因此被处决，而是被送进监狱。但在1885年——这是一个非常复杂的故事，所以我们只讲一个简化版本——出台了一项立法，其初衷其实是为了保护女性，因为当时人们对所谓的“白奴贸易”和年轻女孩被拐卖有着极大的痴迷。
of simplified version. There was legislation which was actually about techting women, because there was a great obsession at the time with what people called the white slave trade and young girls being trafficked. A liberal MP henry labouchere introduced an amendment it's still debated by historians whether he was sort of messing around and wrecking the bill he thought he was wrecking the bill or whether he genuinely believed it because he was a radical he was a sort of tub thumping campaigner but this amendment criminalized not just sodomy but any what they called gross indecency of one male person with another male person and made it a misdemeanor. So it's not a crime. It's a misdemeanor. And
一位自由党下议院议员亨利·拉布谢尔（Henry Labouchere）提出了一项修正案。历史学家们至今仍在争论，他当时是在瞎搞并试图搞砸这项法案（他以为自己是在破坏法案），还是他真的坚信这一点——因为他是一个激进派，一个慷慨激昂的活动家。但这项修正案不仅将鸡奸行为定为刑事犯罪，还将任何所谓的“一个男性与另一个男性之间的严重猥亵行为”定为轻罪（misdemeanor）。所以它不是重罪（crime），而是轻罪。
the maximum sentence is two years with or without hard labor. So in other words, whereas previously you had to be, I mean, to be blunt about it, you had to be convicted of penetration to get into trouble with the law and then you get life imprisonment and then you get yeah a variety of sentences but from 1885 so a year before oscar wilde discovers this taste as it were any form of interaction so any kind of messing around and fumbling and whatever is now liable for prosecution and i think that that only enhances the pleasure for Wilde. So he will come to talk about his relationship with kind of male partners as
最高刑罚是两年监禁，可伴有或不伴有苦役。换句话说，在此之前，你必须——坦率地说——必须被证实存在插入行为才会惹上麻烦，随之而来的是终身监禁以及各种不同的刑罚。但从1885年开始——也就是奥斯卡·王尔德发现这种“爱好”的前一年——任何形式的互动，也就是任何摸索、瞎搞之类的事情，现在都面临着被起诉的风险。我认为这只会增强王尔德的快感。所以他后来会把与男性伴侣的关系称为
feasting with panthers. And I think that for Wilde, that sense of danger absolutely amplifies the pleasure. So he will call his series of relationships with young men feasting with panthers precisely because it is so dangerous. That is clearly, I think, a crucial part of this story. The story of Wilde's trials are situated against this change in the law. But Dominic, I think there's also another, potentially even more intriguing aspect, which is a crucial shift in the understanding of how sexuality functions, of what sexuality actually is. And we are the heirs of this revolution. And the revolution has triumphed
与豹同宴。我认为，对王尔德来说，这种危险感绝对放大了快感。因此，他把与年轻男子的系列关系称为“与豹同宴”，恰恰是因为它如此危险。这显然是这个故事中至关重要的一部分。王尔德受审的故事就发生在这个法律发生变化的背景下。但多米尼克，我认为还有一个潜在的、甚至更耐人寻味的方面，那就是关于性功能如何运作、性究竟是什么的理解发生了一次至关重要的转变。我们正是这场革命的继承者。而这场革命已经取得了胜利，
so completely that perhaps we don't even realize that there's been one. So essentially, that law of Henry VIII that you mentioned, what that is doing is operating on an assumption that sexual acts are moral crimes that they are deliberate actions taken by sinners who are so depraved so evil so much the creature of their lusts that they're not willing to operate within the the kind of the guidelines that god has set so it's moral And they're what you do rather than what you are. It's what you do. So there is no concept that you might, for instance, you might be gay. There's no concept of that at all. But in the second half of the 19th century, this has begun to change. And what you see is the kind of the medicalization of what had previously
以至于我们可能都没有意识到曾经发生过这样一场革命。因此，本质上讲，你提到的亨利八世的那部法律，其运作的前提是：性行为是道德上的犯罪，是罪人们刻意采取的行动。这些罪人如此堕落、如此邪恶、如此受其色欲的驱使，以至于他们不愿在上帝设定的准则内行事，所以这是一个道德问题。这是你“做”的事情，而不是你“是”什么样的人。这是你的所作所为。因此，当时根本没有概念认为你可能，比如说，是个同性恋。这种概念完全不存在。但在19世纪下半叶，这种情况开始发生变化。你看到的是，原本被视为道德进攻的行为，开始被赋予了医学色彩。
been something that was seen as being a moral offense. And this is particularly associated with German psychology. And it's Germans who coined the phrase homosexuality. Yeah. So it's a kind of portmanteau word, mixture of Latin and Greek, like television. And the guy who popularizes it is a German psychologist called Richard von Kraft-Ebbing, who writes this great book about it called The Psychopathia Sexualis, which is translated into English in 1892. So that's three years before Wilde goes to trial. And the thing that's interesting about this is partly that
而这尤其与德国心理学有关。正是德国人创造了“同性恋”这个词。是的。所以这是一个混合词，融合了拉丁语和希腊语，就像“电视”（television）这个词一样。将其普及的人是一位名叫理查德·冯·克拉夫特-埃宾的德国心理学家，他写了一本关于此事的伟大著作《性 psychopathia Sexualis》（性精神病学），该书于1892年被翻译成英文。那是在王尔德受审的三年前。关于这一点，有趣的地方在于，一方面，
Kraft-Ebbing is kind of casting homosexuality, this idea that people have a particular condition, a kind of morbid condition, as he describes it, as a disease, as something that is as a morbidity. And therefore, there is a hint in Kraft-Ebbing that people should be treated with sympathy. And furthermore, by the end of his career, Kraft-Ebbing has come into such kind of contact with people who come to identify themselves as homosexual, that he's arguing that it should be decriminalized completely and that people who are homosexual can lead kind of the equivalent of a married life so he's always kind of prefiguring gay marriage now this matters i think for wild because even as he is sleeping around a lot with young men kind of casual affairs he does meet the great love of his life, who is Alfred Lord Douglas, the son of the Marquess of Queensbury.
克拉夫特-埃宾将同性恋——即人们拥有某种特定状况、一种他所描述的病态状况的想法——塑造为一种疾病，一种病态。因此，在克拉夫特-埃宾的观点中，暗示了人们应该受到同情。此外，到了职业生涯的末期，克拉夫特-埃宾已经与那些开始认同自己是同性恋的人进行了如此多的接触，以至于他主张应该彻底将其非罪化，并且同性恋者可以过上类似于婚姻的生活——所以他某种程度上预见了同性恋婚姻。现在，我认为这对于王尔德来说很重要，因为即使他在与年轻男子鬼混、进行许多随意的风流韵事时，他也遇到了他一生的挚爱，也就是阿尔弗雷德·道格拉斯勋爵，即昆斯伯里侯爵的儿子。
And this sense that homosexual love can be something that is dignified, that it is something that is noble, that it is something that is pure, perhaps even purer and nobler than a kind of conventional heterosexual relationship is something that both wild and bozzi his name for alfred douglas really really get into and it kind of fuses with this greek roman idea well before we get into that before we get to bozzi let's get to the end of the 1880s so wild had sort of had discovered this taste as it were if that's i mean that's obviously not the right expression but you know what i mean in 1886 quite quickly he becomes increasingly reckless so he's having assignations with much younger men men 18 19 20 21 he's in his mid-30s and what's interesting so we have this image i think tom of the late victorians of the sort of the world of the criminalization of homosexual behavior we often think of it as almost totalitarian in its repression but that's not quite right so wild is obviously getting away with this behavior it's an open secret in literary and
这种认为同性之爱可以是尊严的、高贵的、纯洁的，甚至可能比传统的异性恋关系更纯洁、更高贵的观念，是王尔德和博西（他对阿尔弗雷德·道格拉斯的称呼）非常非常投入的，它与这种希腊罗马的理念融合在了一起。好了，在我们深入探讨这个之前，在我们谈到博西之前，让我们先回到19世纪80年代末。所以王尔德当时已经发现了这种“滋味”——如果可以这么说的话（我的意思是，这显然不是正确的表达，但你知道我的意思）。在1886年，他很快变得越来越鲁莽。所以他和比他小得多的年轻男子（18、19、20、21岁，而他当时已经三十多岁）私会。有趣的是，汤姆，我们对维多利亚时代晚期往往有一种印象，即那是将同性恋行为定为刑事犯罪的世界，我们通常认为它的压制几乎是极权主义的，但这并不完全准确。所以王尔德显然一直在侥幸逃脱这种行为，这在伦敦的文学和
theatrical circles in london and indeed elsewhere so rumors kind of spread so when his book the portrait of dorian gray which you mentioned earlier when that comes out in 1890, it's interesting how a lot of the reviews of Dorian Gray see it against the background, I think, of this kind of reckless behavior. So here's the Daily Chronicle. The Daily Chronicle says of Dorian Gray, it's a poisonous tale spawned by the leprous literature of the French decadence, heavy with the odors of moral and spiritual putrefaction. We've all had bad reviews like that. Well, that's what a lot of people say about this podcast.
戏剧界乃至其他地方都是一个公开的秘密。因此谣言四散，当他的小说《道连·格雷的画像》（正如你之前提到的）在1890年出版时，有趣的是，许多对《道连·格雷》的评论都将它与这种鲁莽的行为联系在了一起。来看看《每日纪事报》是怎么说的。《每日纪事报》评价《道连·格雷》说：“这是一部毒害人心的故事，由法国颓废派那长满麻风病的文学孕育而生，弥漫着道德与精神腐败的气息。”我们都写过这样的恶评。好吧，这也是许多人对这个播客的评价。
Here's a much more interesting one. The Scots Observer says, it's the kind of tale that would appeal to none but outlawed noblemen and perverted telegraph boys. Now, why perverted telegraph boys? Well, because a year earlier in 1889, there has been a scandal called the Cleveland Street Scandal, when a homosexual brothel has been exposed. Telegraph boys, so basically messenger boys, are selling themselves to aristocrats. So the most famous example is a guy called Lord Arthur Somerset, who was the equerry to the Prince of Wales. He actually fled abroad to avoid prosecution.
这里有一个更有趣的。《苏格兰观察家报》说：“这种故事除了流亡的贵族和堕落的电报员之外，不会吸引任何人。”现在，为什么要提到“堕落的电报员”呢？嗯，因为一年前的1889年，曾爆发过一起被称为“克利夫兰街丑闻”的事件，当时一家同性恋妓院被曝光。电报员，也就是信差男孩，在把自己出卖给贵族。所以最著名的例子是一个叫阿瑟·萨默塞特勋爵的人，他是威尔士亲王的侍从武官。他实际上逃到了国外以逃避起诉。
So when the paper says this is a tale that will appeal to Telegraph Boys... They understand exactly what the code is in Picture of Dorian Gray. And many readers will also say, ah, so now we know. And of course, the thing about the Telegraph Boys and the aristocrats, also there's something else going on there, which is this suspicion throughout the 1880s, 1890s, 1900s. We talked about it with the Kaiser, actually, in Germany, Tom. This suspicion, which is very widespread in the Western world,
所以当报纸说这是一个会吸引电报员的故事时……他们完全明白《道连·格雷的画像》里的暗语是什么。许多读者也会说：“啊，原来如此，我们懂了。”当然，关于电报员和贵族的事情，还有另一个层面，那就是贯穿整个19世纪80年代、90年代和20世纪的一种猜疑。汤姆，我们之前在德国谈论凯撒时也提到过这一点。这种在西方世界广泛存在的猜疑，
that rich and powerful people are part of this sinister homosexual elite who are secretly having assignations with rent boys. I mean, this is all around in that kind of late Victorian Edwardian world. And again, that feeds into the idea that there is something elevated about Greek love, as both Bosie and Wilde would call it. So Bosie kind of celebrates what he calls a frank paganism, because you have to have, you know, to study Greek and Latin at Oxford or Cambridge, you have to have the education and the class and the background to do it. So let's talk a little bit about Bosie. Bosie is Lord Alfred Douglas. He's the third son of
即富有和权势的人是这个邪恶的同性恋精英集团的一部分，他们秘密地与男妓幽会。我的意思是，在维多利亚时代晚期和爱德华时代的世界里，这种说法随处可见。同样，这也助长了这样一种观念：希腊式的爱有着崇高的地位，正如博西和王尔德所称的那样。因此，博西有点在赞美他所谓的“坦率的异教主义”，因为你必须在牛津或剑桥学习过希腊语和拉丁语，你必须具备相应的教育、阶级和背景才能做到这一点。所以让我们稍微谈谈博西。博西就是阿尔弗雷德·道格拉斯勋爵。他是
the Marquess of Greensbury. So he's the aristocrat who codifies the rules of boxing. Bosie had... And he's very much the kind of man who you would associate with codifies the rules of boxing. Bosie had... And he's very much the kind of man who you would associate with codifying the laws of boxing. He's got tremendous side whiskers, hasn't he? And he's terrifying. Yeah. He's a sort of hulking figure who crosses London,
昆斯伯里侯爵的三儿子。也就是那位为拳击规则编纂成册的贵族。博西有……而且他非常符合那种你会联想到编纂拳击规则的人。博西有……他非常符合那种你会将其与编纂拳击法律联系在一起的人。他留着巨大的络腮胡，不是吗？而且他很吓人。是的。他是一个在伦敦横行霸道、
falling out with people. He's a very keen secularist, Tom. Yes, he is. He disrupted an Alfred Lord Tennyson play because it had a disobliging portrait of an atheist. And he has been thrown out of the theatre for shouting. So he a very strange figure the marquis of greensbury eccentric maverick badly behaved dangerous enemy to have yeah very dangerous enemy so wild meets bozzi who's 20 in 1891 they start an affair in 1892 but i think think, Dominic, important just to emphasize that Bosie is much more experienced than Wilde in terms of gay relationships.
到处与人交恶的庞大身影。汤姆，他是一个非常坚定的世俗主义者。是的，没错。他曾大闹阿尔弗雷德·丁尼生的戏剧，因为剧中对一个无神论者的描绘不够客气。他因为大喊大叫而被赶出了剧院。所以他是一个非常奇怪的人物——昆斯伯里侯爵，一个古怪的独行侠、行为恶劣、是个危险的敌人。是的，非常危险的敌人。因此，王尔德在1891年遇到了20岁的博西，他们在1892年开始了一段婚外情。但我认为，多米尼克，重要的是要强调，就同性恋关系而言，博西比王尔德更有经验。
Yes, he is. So he's been having relationships at Winchester at school and at Oxford. They immediately strike up. I mean, what some people, so I mean, I'll put my cards on the table. I think Bosie was an absolutely terrible, terrible man. Terrible piece of work. Yeah. Yes. And they strike up what I think a lot of people including some of wild's friends would say is a
是的，他确实如此。他在温彻斯特学校和牛津就一直保持着这种关系。他们一拍即合。我的意思是，有些人——把我的底牌亮出来吧——我认为博西是一个极其糟糕、极其糟糕的人。一个彻头彻尾的混蛋。是的。是的。他们建立了一段我认为包括王尔德的一些朋友在内都会认为是的
toxic relationship it's a relationship that is very bad for wild so they haven't actually been together very long as it were in august 1892 wild has taken a house in norfolk a sort of summer home for his family he invites invites Bosie along. He and Bosie stay there. And Bosie, from that point, it seems that Bosie basically introduces Wilde to this world in which Wilde had previously only dabbled, which is the world of,
有毒的关系。这段关系对王尔德非常有害。所以他们其实并没有在一起很长时间。1892年8月，王尔德在诺福克租了一栋房子，算是为家人准备的度假屋。他邀请了博西一同前往。他和博西住在了那里。从那时起，似乎博西基本上把王尔德引入了这样一个世界：在这个世界里，王尔德以前只是浅尝辄止，那就是……
there are places in London, despite the fact that homosexuality is criminalized, there are places in London where you can pick up rent boys there's a roller skating rink in knightsbridge the roller skate i mean it's so unexpected i know it's very 50s america milkshakes there's the bar at the st james's restaurant if you know you know and you go to these places and you pick up 17 18 19, 19-year-old young men. And they behave. It staggers me, you know, thinking about this story.
伦敦有一些地方，尽管同性恋被定为刑事犯罪，但在伦敦依然有可以招揽男妓的地方。骑士桥有一家轮滑溜冰场——轮滑，我的意思是这太出乎意料了。我知道，这很像50年代的美国奶昔。圣詹姆斯餐厅里还有酒吧，懂的自然懂。你去这些地方，搭讪17、18、19岁的年轻男子。而他们的行为……每当想到这个故事，我都感到震惊。
They behave with extraordinary recklessness. Knowing the climate of the time, they are picking up rent boys. We could give example after example, but the biographies are very similar. These are 19, 20-year-old clerks, office boys, servants, waiters. They're always inferior, socially inferior. But they are behaving, Tom. They are taking rooms at the Savoy and things. There's two brothers, Charlie and William Parker, for example.
他们的行为极其鲁莽。在当时的氛围下，他们居然在招揽男妓。我们可以举出一个又一个例子，但传记中的经历都非常相似。这些都是19、20岁的职员、办公室杂役、仆人、侍者。他们的社会地位总是低人一等的。但汤姆，他们的行为却很大胆。他们在萨伏伊酒店等地开房间。比如，有查理和威廉·帕克这对兄弟，
Bozy lets them sleep in his bed. He lets them sleep in his bed so that the servants will see the next day. Wild at the Savoy, when the pages at the savoy come to bring him messages he thanks them by kissing them on the mouth which they find very alarming and then he gives them money yes so wild wild's approach to these boys i think you can call them boys because i mean they are pretty young is simultaneously he is a very kind. He's very generous. He's a great one handing out silver cigarette boxes. He does that all the time. I mean, he behaves well with them in that sense. He's a kind man. But at the same time, this is clearly very exploitative. He is much older. He's
博西让他们睡在自己的床上。他让他们睡在自己的床上，好让仆人们第二天看到。在萨伏伊酒店，当萨伏伊的信差来给他送信时，王尔德通过亲吻他们的嘴来感谢他们，这让他们感到非常惊恐，然后他会给他们钱。是的，所以王尔德对这些男孩的态度——我认为可以叫他们男孩，因为他们确实很年轻——一方面他非常善良。他非常慷慨。他总是喜欢送出银制的烟盒。他一直都在这么做。我的意思是，从这个意义上说，他对他们很好。他是个善良的人。但与此同时，这显然具有很强的剥削性。他年长得多，
much richer. He's in a position of power relative to them. And as we will find out in due course, when they are cited in the trial, Wilde's actions with them seems to have caused them quite a lot of psychological distress. So this is a fascinating question, which we, I mean, I guess listeners to the podcast will draw their own conclusions, and that will depend very much on your position, as it were.
富有得多。相对于他们，他处于权力上位。正如我们日后将发现的那样，当他们被传唤出庭时，王尔德对他们的所作所为似乎给他们带来了相当大的心理痛苦。所以这是一个迷人且引人深思的问题，我想，播客的听众们会得出各自的结论，这很大程度上取决于你的立场。
But obviously there are two different ways of seeing this. One is to say Wilde is the victim of this incredibly censorious puritanical culture and he is martyr another way of seeing it which perhaps people in 2023 might be more inclined to do is to say wild is exploiting a power and wealth and i think wild himself would accept that so in due course you know he says about this time i grew careless of the lives of others which doesn't mean that he is regretting it, because for Wilde, the idea of paradox is incredibly important. The idea that you can be two things at once simultaneously is the whole essence of his understanding of what character is.
但显然有两种不同的看法。一种看法是，王尔德是这种令人发指的清教徒文化受害者，他是一个殉道者；另一种看法——2023年的人们可能更倾向于这样做——是认为王尔德在利用自己的权力和财富，我想王尔德本人也会承认这一点。所以在适当的时候，你知道，他关于这段时间曾说过：“我开始不在乎别人的生活”，这并不意味着他在后悔，因为对王尔德来说，悖论的概念极其重要。能够同时具有两种身份的理念，正是他理解性格本质的全部核心。
And also, he is very, very committed to the idea that genius, and particularly artistic genius, means that you are emancipated from the standards of kind of broader more conventional society so all of this is part of the kind of psychological mix of what is going on one quick thing tom some people may be wondering where's his wife and all this constance and the answer is she's at home with the kids he's constantly saying well i have to go to the savoy i have to go go and... And so hence the Bunbury thing. I mean, so when he comes to write The Importance of Being Earnest, you know, it's on the surface,
而且，他非常非常坚信，天才，尤其是艺术天才，意味着你已经从更广泛、更传统的社会的标准中解放出来了。所以所有这些都是其中正在发生的心理交织的一部分。还有一个小问题，汤姆，有些人可能想知道：康斯坦丝（他的妻子）在这期间在哪里？答案是她在家带孩子。他总是说：“哦，我得去萨伏伊，我得去……”因此就有了“本伯里”这个梗。所以，当他开始写《认真的重要性》时，表面上看，
it seems a completely heterosexual play. But the moment you realize what all these jokes are about, the fact, you know, Bunbury and so on, this is exactly what Wilde is doing. But Tom, I mean, just on Constance, she's always left out of this story. She is innocent of all this.'s when i say innocent she has no conception of what is going on and she is distressed that wild is going off and leaving her and at one point she she's still
这似乎是一部完全异性恋的戏剧。但一旦你意识到所有这些笑话到底在讲什么——比如本伯里等等——这正是王尔德在做的事情。但是汤姆，关于康斯坦丝，她总是被排除在这个故事之外。她对这一切一无所知。当我说是“一无所知”时，她是完全无法理解正在发生什么，她只是为王尔德离家出走而感到痛苦，并且有一段时间，她甚至还在
bringing him by the way his post so he will check into a hotel with bozie douglas she will bring him his post on one occasion she says to, when are you going to come home? And Wilde, in that flippant, dismissive way that he has, says, oh, I've been gone so long that I can't even remember the address.
给他送邮件。所以，当他与博西·道格拉斯入住某家酒店时，她会给他送去邮件。有一次，她对他说：“你什么时候才肯回家？”王尔德用他那种轻浮、冷漠的语气回答说：“我离开太久了，连地址都记不得了。”
And you sort of think there is a sad side to that story. It's funny and sad, exactly. So, meanwhile, Wilde's name is starting to be, become tainted by this in the view of the broader public. So here's one story.
你会有种感觉，这个故事里有着悲伤的一面。既好笑又悲伤，确实如此。与此同时，在公众眼中，王尔德的名字开始因这件事而遭到玷污。所以这里有一个故事。
They take a cottage in Goring by the Thames. The vicar comes around one day to see Oscar Wilde. Which is very important to being earnest. And Wilde is lying there in the garden without just a towel. Bosie is completely naked. They've been dousing each other with the hosepipe. They are perfectly Greek-seeming,
他们在泰晤士河畔戈林租了一座小屋。一天，牧师来拜访奥斯卡·王尔德——这与《认真的重要性》情节非常契合。王尔德正躺在花园里，身上只围了一条毛巾。博西则赤身裸体。他们一直在用水管互相喷水。他们表现得就像古希腊人描绘的那样完美，
they describe it as. And there are stories that in Goring, it's an open secret at this point, the goes that at the pub the local pub the people are saying i'd like to go and punch that oscar wilde he's a terrible man what are they getting up to in that cottage so a lot of people now know and this is very like the plot of dorian gray where the reputation of dorian gray becomes steadily more and more evil and there's a sense in which Wilde is almost kind of reveling in the way that he is repeating the plot of that. But what really turbocharges the sense in the kind of general public that Wilde is indeed feasting with panthers is the behavior of Boese's father,
他们自己也这样形容。有传言说，在戈林，这当时已经成了公开的秘密。据说在当地的酒吧里，人们都在议论：“我想去揍那个奥斯卡·王尔德一顿，他是个混蛋，他们在那个小屋里到底在搞什么鬼？”所以现在很多人都知道了，这非常像《道连·格雷》的剧情——道连·格雷的名声变得越来越邪恶，某种意义上，王尔德几乎是在沉溺于自己正在重演这部小说情节的快感中。但是，真正让普通大众确信王尔德确实在“与豹同宴”的，是博西父亲的行为，
the Marcus of Queensbury. Oh, yeah. So the Marcus of Queensbury sees them. I mean, he has met Wilde and he's seen them together. He thinks, you know, my son has a friend who is a very famous and important man. But by the spring of 1894, you know, he's heard all the rumours.
也就是昆斯伯里侯爵。哦，是的。所以昆斯伯里侯爵看到了他们。我的意思是，他见过王尔德，也见过他们在一起。他原本觉得：“你知道的，我儿子有个非常著名且重要的人物做朋友。”但到了1894年春天，你知道的，他听到了所有的传闻。
He writes to Bosie, with my own eyes, I saw you both in the most loathsome and disgusting relationship as expressed by your manner and expression. You're disgusted, so-called father, Queensbury. To which Bosie's reply, sent by telegram, is, what a funny little man you are. Yeah, but Queensbury then says to him,
他写信给博西：“我亲眼看到你们两个在那种最令人厌恶、最恶心的关系中，你们的神情和表现表露无遗。你那令人作呕的所谓父亲，昆斯伯里。”博西随后通过电报回复道：“你真是个滑稽的小矮人啊。”是的，但随后昆斯伯里对他说：
if I catch you again with that man, I'll make a public scandal in a way you little dream of. And a few weeks later, he actually goes around to Wilde's house. This is June 1894. Wilde says to him, I mean, Wilde is so, so reckless. He says him are you i mean wild is so so reckless he says are you seriously accusing me of sodomy and the marcus says i don't say you are but you look it and you poses it which is just as bad you know they have this massive argument queensbury says to him if i catch you and my son together in any public restaurant i will thrash you so this is that tells you the sort of man marcus queensberry is now even at that stage wild i mean just unbelievably self-destructively given what's to happen it's already
“如果我再抓到你和那个男人在一起，我会以你做梦也想不到的方式制造一场公开的丑闻。”几个星期后，他真的去了王尔德的家。那是1894年6月。王尔德对他说——我的意思是，王尔德实在是太鲁莽了——他对他说：“你是在认真指控我犯了鸡奸罪吗？”侯爵说：“我没说你犯了，但你看起来就是那样，而且你摆出那样的姿态，这同样糟糕。”你知道，他们爆发了一场激烈的争吵。昆斯伯里对他说：“如果我和我儿子在任何公共餐厅抓到你，我会狠狠揍你一顿。”这就能看出昆斯伯里侯爵是个什么样的人了。然而即使在那个阶段，王尔德——真是不可思议地自我毁灭，考虑到接下来要发生的事情——其实已经
saying to his lawyers i'd like to sue the marquis of queensberry you know i'd like to take legal action against him for libeling me i mean this is crazy given that actually what the marcus of queensberry is saying is true yes so tom i mean the story gets so i mean it becomes the Marcus of Greensby is saying is true. Yes. So, Tom, I mean, the story gets so, I mean, it becomes the stuff of a pure Victorian melodrama, doesn't it? It does. The first night of the importance of being earnest. Yes. The libel case, the trial, and then subsequent trials.
在对他的律师说：“我想起诉昆斯伯里侯爵，你知道的，我想对他的诽谤行为采取法律行动。”我的意思是，考虑到昆斯伯里侯爵所说的是事实，这简直是疯了。是的，所以汤姆，这个故事变得……我的意思是，它成了纯粹的维多利亚式情节剧的素材，不是吗？确实如此。《认真的重要性》首演夜。是的。诽谤案、审判，以及随后的审判。
So let's take a break before we plunge headlong into the seething stew of resentments, anxieties, accusations, and high melodrama. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
所以在我们一头扎进充斥着怨恨、焦虑、指控和高级情节剧的沸腾大熔炉之前，先休息一下。等一下，朱莉到底喜欢哪种浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单是不是太迟了？但如果你有一台KitchenAid的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会想这些了，因为你完全可以在家里自己做咖啡。现在就去 KitchenAid.ca 选购吧。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦点缀，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告版节目、获取独家番外节目并提早购买现场活动门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to the rest is history we are talking the trials of oscar wilde and dominic we are approaching the first of those trials which is when wilde sues the marcus of queensbury the father of his lover bozzi for libel and it's a kind of mad thing for wilde to do isn't it it's completely mad it's completely mad so he's been threatened by the marcus greensbury the shadow the hulking shadow of this boxing enthusiast is hanging never take on a boxing enthusiast never is hanging over him and yet even now so by the way in the summer of 1894 just after he's had these threats wild is writing the play that we opened with the importance of being honest in worthing in worthing which so hence jack worthing and here's an example of wild's recklessness
51|||大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》，我们正在讨论奥斯卡·王尔德的审判，多米尼克，我们即将接近其中第一场审判，那就是王尔德起诉昆斯伯里侯爵——他的同性恋人波西的父亲——犯有诽谤罪，王尔德做这件事简直太疯狂了，不是吗？这完全是疯狂的，完全是疯狂的，所以他受到了昆斯伯里侯爵的威胁，这个拳击迷高大魁梧的阴影永远不要和一个拳击迷较劲，绝不要，这个阴影一直笼罩着他，然而即使到了现在，顺便说一句，在1894年夏天，就在他遭到这些威胁之后，王尔德正在写我们在开头播出的那部戏剧《不可儿戏》，在沃兴，在沃兴，所以才有了杰克·沃兴，这就是王尔德鲁莽的一个例子。
he's in worthing that summer on the beach he's got bozzie douglas with him he's got his family his sons they pick up a trio of boys on the beach most famously a guy called alphonse conway who wild calls alfonso alfonso is 16 wild invites him out in dinghies and stuff you know going crabbing or whatever they do with wild's children but when they will get back you know when the children go to bed or whatever wild will go off with alfonso and there's a you know he will and i quote take hold of alfonso and fumble with him. How old is Alfonso? Alfonso is 16. So Alfonso, I think it's fair to describe Alfonso. He's not a young man.
他那年夏天在沃兴的海滩上，波西·道格拉斯和他在一起，他的家人、儿子们也都在，他们在海滩上结识了三个男孩，其中最著名的是一个叫阿方索·康威的家伙，王尔德管他叫阿方索，阿方索16岁，王尔德邀请他去划小艇之类的，你知道的，去抓螃蟹或者他们和王尔德的孩子们一起做的任何事情，但当他们回来的时候，你知道的，当孩子们上床睡觉或者别的什么的时候，王尔德会和阿方索一起离开，而且你知道的，他会，我引述一下，“抓住阿方索并对他动手动脚”。阿方索多大？阿方索16岁。所以阿方索，我认为用这个词来形容阿方索很公平，他不是一个年轻男子。
He is a boy. And I think from the perspective of 2023, that's a story that makes uncomfortable reading. Don't you think, Tom, makes uncomfortable reading? And given the circumstances, so he knows this bloke is out there threatening to thrash him, to make a public scandal. I think just crazily reckless.
他是一个男孩。而且我认为从2023年的角度来看，这是一个让人读起来很不舒服的故事。你不觉得吗，汤姆，让人读起来很不舒服？考虑到当时的处境，他知道这家伙在外面威胁要狠狠揍他一顿，要制造一个公开的丑闻。我认为这简直是疯狂的鲁莽。
And so this play that he's written in Worthing while all this is going on, The Importance of Being Earnest, comes on stage at St. James' Theatre, 14th of February, so Valentine's Day, 1895. And it's this shimmering play about people leading secret lives in which nothing is quite as it seems. And it's a triumphant success. It's a brilliant play. Wilde is now the literary toast of London, but this shadow remains because the Marquess of Queensbury has been prowling around the theatre trying to get access. He can't get in and he has with him a grotesque bouquet of vegetables yeah which he he he wants to give to wild he can't get in and so he kind of storms off the description chattering like a monstrous ape so i mean it's kind of terrifying figure uh and so that's absolutely of course a shadow over the success of the importance
所以他在这一切正在发生的时候在沃兴写的这部戏剧《不可儿戏》，于1895年2月14日情人节在圣詹姆斯剧院上演。这是一部闪耀的戏剧，讲述人们过着秘密的生活，其中一切似乎都并非如此。这是一场轰动的成功。这是一部精彩的戏剧。王尔德现在是伦敦文学界的宠儿，但这个阴影依然存在，因为昆斯伯里侯爵一直在剧院周围徘徊，试图混进去。他进不去，他带了一束古怪的蔬菜花束，是的，他想把它送给王尔德，但他进不去，所以他气冲冲地走了，描述说他“像一只畸形的猿猴一样喋喋不休”，所以我的意思是，这真是一个可怕的人物，呃，所以这当然绝对给《不可儿戏》的成功蒙上了一层阴影。
of the very next day tom the very next day wild again consults his lawyers and says i'd like to prosecute the marcus of queensbury get him off my case and so it's two weeks later isn't it tom that 28th of february he gets the provocation the fateful provocation that pushes him over the edge yes so he goes to the albemarle club and there a porter hands over this missive this note that has been left for him by the Marks of Queensbury. The porter has very discreetly put it in an envelope. Wilde takes it out. And here is this kind of
就在第二天，汤姆，就在第二天，王尔德再次咨询他的律师，说我想起诉昆斯伯里侯爵，让他别再纠缠我。所以两周后，不是吗，汤姆，2月28日，他得到了那个挑衅，那个把他逼上绝境的命运般的挑衅，是的，所以他去了阿尔伯马尔俱乐部，在那里，一个门房递给他这封信，这是昆斯伯里侯爵留给他的便条。门房非常谨慎地把它装在一个信封里。王尔德把它抽了出来。这里就是这种。
notorious accusation that Oscar Wilde is a ponce and a somdomite. Yeah, so it's at first, that's exactly what Wilde thinks it is. It's ponce and somdomite. But I think, I mean, the Marks of Queensbury has,
臭名昭著的指控，称奥斯卡·王尔德是一个皮条客和鸡奸者。是的，所以一开始，王尔德正是这么认为的。这就是皮条客和鸡奸者。但我的意思是，昆斯伯里侯爵有。
as monstrous apes tend to do, he has terrible handwriting. So I think the consensus is that actually it's posing sondermite or something like this. And Wilde goes to see Bosie and his friend, Robbie Ross, the very person who'd introduced him to homosexuality. And they say, yeah, go for it. Prosecute him. I mean, mad, by the way, completely mad. But the plan is that Wilde and Douglas are going to defend their relationship as something exalted, as something Greek, as something platonic, as something Shakespearean, and make the Marx of Queensbury look like a kind of gibbering ape. Yeah. It's basically the plan. It is the plan. And what, and Bosie, I mean, he says to Wilde, oh, sure,
正如畸形的猿猴往往会做的那样，他有一手糟糕的字迹。所以我认为大家的共识是，实际上它是“摆姿势的鸡奸者”或者类似的话。王尔德去找波西和他的朋友罗比·罗丝，正是这个人把他引入了同性恋。他们说，去吧。起诉他。我的意思是，疯狂的，顺便说一句，完全疯狂的。但计划是王尔德和道格拉斯要将他们的关系辩护为一种崇高的事物、一种希腊式的事物、一种柏拉图式的事物、一种莎士比亚式的事物，并让昆斯伯里侯爵看起来像个胡言乱语的猿猴。是的。这基本上就是计划。这就是计划。而且，波西，我的意思是，他对王尔德说，哦，当然。
it'll be very expensive, but don't worry, I'll pay for it. My family all hates my father. We'll all pay for it. We will basically put up the money for you to prosecute my father. So Wilde issues the writ and Marcus of Queensbury is arrested and he's brought to Marlborough Street Magistrate's Court and charged with publishing a criminal libel. Yeah. Now, the first thing that Marcuscus queensberry does is he engages somebody who will be well known to people who've listened to our recent episodes so he engages a
这会非常昂贵，但别担心，我会付钱的。我的家人都恨我父亲。我们都会付钱的。我们基本上会出资让你起诉我父亲。所以王尔德发出了传票，昆斯伯里侯爵被捕，并被带到马尔伯勒街地方法 magistrate 法庭，被指控犯有刑事诽谤罪。是的。现在，昆斯伯里侯爵做的第一件事就是聘请了一个人，这个人对于听过我们最近几集节目的听众来说会很熟悉，所以他聘请了一个。
man who had been at university with oscar wilde who is edward carson later very famously the leader of the ulster unionists the great champion of anti-home rule ulster Unionism in the early 1910s. Now, this is always this sort of clash of the two men. It's almost always actually presented as kind of morality story with Carson as the villain. The interesting thing, actually, is that Carson didn't really want to take the case. First of all, he didn't like the idea of appearing against an old school friend. And also, he thought the Marquess of Queensbury's case was too weak. And the other interesting thing is that actually Wilde's solicitor had wanted to retain Carson for Wilde,
曾与奥斯卡·王尔德一同上过大学的人，名叫爱德华·卡森，后来大名鼎鼎的阿尔斯特统一主义领袖，20世纪10年代初反对自治的阿尔斯特统一主义的伟大捍卫者。现在，这总是这两种人的某种冲突。它几乎总是被呈现为一个道德故事，卡森扮演反派。有趣的是，实际上卡森并不太想接这个案子。首先，他不喜欢与老校友对簿公堂的想法。而且，他认为昆斯伯里侯爵的案子太弱了。另一个有趣的事实是，实际上王尔德的律师曾想为王尔德聘请卡森。
but had been beaten to the punch by the other side. Because Carson already has a reputation as this brilliant courtroom performer. Absolutely ruthless, devastating and placable and it's a bad way for wild that carson is on the other side i mean he gets a very very distinguished defense lawyer sir edward clark whose descendant tom is a member of the rest of history club it's wonderful to know isn't it peter clark kc so there you go so sir edward asks wild is there any truth in these accusations, as he has to? And Wilde says, absolutely none.
但被对方抢先了一步。因为卡森已经享有这种出色的法庭表演者的声誉。绝对冷酷无情、毁灭性且毫不妥协，对于王尔德来说，卡森站在对立面是一个坏兆头，我的意思是，他找了一位非常非常杰出的辩护律师爱德华·克拉克爵士，汤姆，他的后代是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，知道这一点真是太棒了，对吧，彼得·克拉克御用大律师（KC）？所以就是这样，所以爱德华爵士问王尔德，这些指控有任何真实性吗，正如他必须问的那样？王尔德说，绝对没有。
And so Clark prepares his defense on that assumption. On that assumption, exactly. But even at the very beginning, so the committal hearing, that's Saturday the 9th of March, even at that early stage, so when the Marcus of Queensbury has been committed for trial, Wilde is making a series of disastrous errors. So he turns up in this dark blue velvet overcoat, a white flower in his buttonhole, you know, the picture of aesthetic dandyism. His answers to the questions are flippant.
所以克拉克就在这个假设下准备他的辩护。完全在这个假设下。但即使在最初阶段，也就是初审听证会，那是3月9日星期六，甚至在那个早期阶段，当昆斯伯里侯爵被交付审判时，王尔德正在犯下一系列灾难性的错误。他穿着这件深蓝色天鹅绒大衣，西装翻领上别着一朵白花，你知道的，一副唯美主义花花公子的形象。他对问题的回答很轻浮。
And, you know, are you a dramatist and author? I believe I am well known as a dramatist and author. And the magistrate says, just answer the question. Yes or no. There's all this kind of thing. Bosie, who's completely deluded, is going around saying everything is splendid. It's going to be a walkover. And actually, most people seem to assume that Wilde is going to lose.
而且，你知道的，“你是一个剧作家和作家吗？”“我相信我作为一名剧作家和作家是广为人知的。”地方法官说：“只回答问题。是或不是。”有所有这种事情。完全被迷惑的波西四处宣说一切都好。这将是一场毫无悬念的胜利。而实际上，大多数人似乎都认为王尔德会输。
So, yeah, even at this very, very early stage, they have a friend called Frank Harris, who's a publisher. And Wilde says to Frank Harris, will you give evidence on my behalf? And Frank Harris actually says, I don't think you're going to win. I mean, everybody knows you're... And starts to suggest, which will become a suggestion that is increasingly made to Wilde,
所以，是的，甚至在这个非常非常早期的阶段，他们有一个叫弗兰克·哈里斯的朋友，他是一位出版商。王尔德对弗兰克·哈里斯说，你会为我出庭作证吗？而弗兰克·哈里斯实际上说，我不认为你会赢。我的意思是，每个人都知道你是……并开始建议，这将成为一个越来越多地向王尔德提出的建议。
that he should basically run away to France. So even at this stage, some of Wilde's friends are saying, but we all know that you have no case but wild and bozzi bozzi is such a terrible person tom wild and bozzi are just in their little bubble aren't they they are consumed with contempt for the marquis of greensbury and i think for the kind of the philistinism of british society generally that doesn't have fine aesthetic feelings and doesn't know what it's like to be plato or shakespeare i think that's also a part of it there's a kind of a cultural elitism there's an arrogance actually and i think that well you
他基本上应该逃到法国去。所以甚至在这个阶段，王尔德的一些朋友都在说，但我们都知道你根本没有胜算，但是王尔德和波西——波西真是个糟糕的人，汤姆——王尔德和波西只是沉浸在他们自己的小泡沫里，不是吗？他们对昆斯伯里侯爵以及我认为对整个英国社会缺乏精美审美感受、不知道成为柏拉图或莎士比亚是什么感觉的庸俗作风充满了蔑视，我认为这也是其中的一部分，有一种文化精英主义，实际上有一种傲慢，而且我认为你。
could call it you would call it arrogant i would call it elitist right you'd call it fine feelings elevated feelings but i think given the stakes given the danger it's crazy that they are charging ahead as they are so and it's a saturday morning the last saturday in march 1895 and the marcus of queensbury has to enter a plea of justification you know his lawyers have to present his case and to say why he's justified in making this claim. And to Wilde's shock and horror, they say, he thinks it's all going to be, has books, I mean, so self-deluding. And actually they say, we have a list as long as our arm. Of all these boys.
你可以称之为，你会称之为傲慢，我会称之为精英主义，对吧？你会称之为美好的情感、崇高的情感，但考虑到利害关系、考虑到危险，他们像现在这样一意孤行实在是太疯狂了。所以这是一个星期六的早晨，1895年3月的最后一个星期六，昆斯伯里侯爵不得不提出无罪抗辩（注：此处原文plea of justification意为“证实抗辩/提出正当理由抗辩”），你知道的，他的律师必须提出他的案子，并说明他提出这种说法的理由。令王尔德震惊和惊恐的是，他们说，他以为这一切都会——有书信，我的意思是，真是自欺欺人。实际上他们说，我们有一份长得像手臂一样的名单。所有这些男孩的名单。
Of all these boys. Our solicitors have engaged investigators. They have tracked down Edward Shelley, Sidney Mavor, Fred Atkins, Maurice Schwab, Alfred Wood, Charles Parker, Walter Granger, Alphonse Conway, this list of three years' worth of assignations. And Wilde is absolutely stunned. And it's at that point for the first time that he thinks,
所有这些男孩的名单。我们的律师聘请了调查人员。他们追踪到了爱德华·谢利、西德尼·梅沃、弗雷德·阿特金斯、莫里斯·施瓦布、阿尔弗雷德·伍德、查尔斯·帕克、沃尔特·格兰杰、阿尔方索·康威，这份长达三年的私会名单。而王尔德彻底惊呆了。正是在那个时候，他第一次想到。
geez, if I lose this case, what will happen is the crown will immediately launch a case against me. The problem is, is that if he does flee abroad, then that's an admission of guilt as well. And again, he'll be ruined. So either way, both alternatives are disastrous. And so he decides he's the most articulate man of his generation. And I think he views Edward Carson as a second rate mind yeah he does knows him from school and thinks i'm going to trust my own oratory my own brilliance and hope that i can command the courtroom so the case opens the full trial opens on wednesday the 3rd of april 1895 at the old bailey at central Criminal Court in the Old Bailey.
天哪，如果我输了这场官司，接下来发生的事将是皇家立即对我提起诉讼。问题是，如果他真的逃往国外，那也是认罪的承认。同样，他也会身败名裂。所以无论如何，这两种选择都是灾难性的.因此他决定他是他那一代人中最口齿伶俐的人。而且我认为他将爱德华·卡森视为一个二流头脑，是的，他确实这么认为。他从学校就认识他，并认为我要相信我自己的雄辩术、我自己的才华，并希望我能驾驭法庭。所以案件开审了，全面审判于1895年4月3日星期三在老贝利中央刑事法院开庭。在老贝利。
For our overseas listeners, I mean, this is the great cockpit of the British legal system. You know, that gives you a sense of what a tremendous drama this is. From the start, Wilder's still playing the kind of flippant, the jokey remarks and all this, and he clearly,
对于我们海外的听众来说，我的意思是，这是英国法律系统的核心主战场。你知道的，这让你对这是一场多么巨大的戏剧有了一种感觉。从一开始，王尔德仍在扮演那种轻浮、开玩笑的言论和所有这一切，他显然。
he has contempt, as you said, for Carson. He thinks Carson's a second rate rate he does say to his counsel no doubt carson will perform his task with all the added bitterness of an old friend yes and he's right he's not wrong because wild is getting the laughs in court but carson is landing the blows which register with the jury because the jury are north london shopkeepers all men of course as was the way in those days wild is making the jokes carson is unsmiling he is cold he just asks his questions again and again so there's a thing right at the beginning carson is able to demonstrate that wild has been lying about his age that actually how old are you mr wild the wild lies and this is kind of riff on a joke in the Importance of Being Earnest, where Lady Bracknell
正如你所说，他对卡森充满蔑视。他认为卡森是个二流货色，他确实对他的辩护律师说，毫无疑问，卡森会带着老朋友所有的额外痛苦来完成他的任务，是的，他是对的，他没有错，因为王尔德在法庭上逗笑了大家，但卡森正在打出能引起陪审团共鸣的重拳，因为陪审团是北伦敦的店主，全都是男性，当然，就像那个时代的方式一样，王尔德在开玩笑，卡森面无表情，他很冷漠，他只是一次又一次地提出他的问题。所以在一开始就有一件事，卡森能够证明王尔德一直在隐瞒自己的年龄，实际上，“你多大，王尔德先生？”王尔德撒谎了，这有点像《不可儿戏》中一个笑话的翻版，布拉克尔内夫人。
says that, you know, it's very bad form to give your real age. No one does this in polite society. But here it's not funny. Because Wilde says, I'm 39. And Carson says, but you're not, are you, Mr. Wilde? You're 40. And right from the start, it makes Wilde look unreliable. It accentuates the age gap between him and all these people.
说，你知道的，在真实的年龄上撒谎是非常糟糕的礼仪。在文明社会里没有人这样做。但在这里这并不好笑。因为王尔德说，我39岁。而卡森说，但你不是，对吗，王尔德先生？你40岁。从一开始，这就让王尔德看起来不可靠。它加剧了他和所有人之间的年龄差距。
But also all his witticisms are so brilliant. They kind of dazzle, but they don't build up a coherent, solid case. No. And Carson, his questions are implacable. Did you ask Ward to your house in Tite Street? Was your wife away? Did you have immoral practices with Ward? Did you open his trousers?
而且他的所有警句都太 brillante（精妙）了。它们有点耀眼，但它们并没有建立一个连贯、坚实的辩护案件。没有。卡森的问题是毫不妥协的。你曾邀请沃德去你在泰特街的房子吗？你妻子不在家吗？你和沃德有过不道德的行为吗？你解开过他的裤子吗？
Did Shelley stay all night? Did you put your hand upon his person? Did you kiss Conway on the Lansing Road? Again and again, again names dates places and the impression is as you said it's one of complete implacability wild makes this totally catastrophic error doesn't he tom yeah they move on to this guy who's a servant called walter granger who was 17 who bozey had interfered with carson did you kiss him? Wilde says, oh no,
谢利留宿过整晚吗？你把手放在他的身上了吗？你在兰辛路上吻过康威吗？一次又一次，名字、日期、地点，给人的印象正如你所说，是完全的冷漠无情。王尔德犯了这样一个彻底灾难性的错误，不是吗，汤姆？是的，他们转向了这个叫沃尔特·格兰杰的仆人，他当时17岁，波西曾与他有过染指，卡森问：你吻过他吗？王尔德说，哦，不。
never in my life. He was such a peculiarly plain boy. Kind of flippant witticism tossed out. And Carson, he was what?
我一生中从未有过。他是一个特别相貌平平的男孩。一种轻浮的妙语随口抛出。卡森说，他是什么？
And then Wilde starts to stutter and says, oh, his appearance was so very unfortunately ugly. I pitied him for his appearance.
然后王尔德开始结结巴巴地说，哦，他的外表太不幸地丑陋了。我为他的外表感到遗憾。
Very ugly, says Carson. And then, why did you mention his ugliness? And he says that question, it's very Jeremy Paxman, which our British listeners his appearance. Very ugly, says Carson. And then, why did you mention his ugliness? And he says that question. It's very Jeremy Paxman, which our British listeners will recognize.
“非常丑陋，”卡森说。然后，“你为什么要提到他的丑陋？”他说这个问题，非常像杰米·帕克斯曼（Jeremy Paxman），我们的英国听众会认出这一点。他的外表非常丑陋，卡森说。然后，你为什么要提到他的丑陋？他说这个问题。这非常像杰米·帕克斯曼，我们的英国听众会认出这一点。
It's a tigerish interviewer. He says again and again, why did you mention his ugliness? Why did you mention his ugliness? Again and again. And while complete, so you sting me and insult me and try to unnerve me.
这是一个老虎般的采访者。他一次又一次地问：你为什么要提到他的丑陋？你为什么要提到他的丑陋？一次又一次。而王尔德完全——所以你羞辱我、侮辱我并试图让我心慌意乱。
And at times one says things flippantly when one ought to speak more seriously. I admit it. Yeah yeah you have the sense here that wild is suddenly realizing that wit is not enough now there's one other moment at this point and the carson interrogation which is day two of the trial carson reads out the letters of the marquis of queens Wilde. And in one of those letters, Queensbury has described Wilde as a damned cur and coward of the Rosebery type. Lord Rosebery is the leader of the Liberal Party and Prime Minister. So around Lord Rosebery, there have been swirling for months allegations and rumours that he too is gay. I mean, amazingly, Dominic, there is a further connection here with the Marquess of Queensbury, right? Exactly. Because the Marquess of Queensbury's eldest son,
有时人们在应当更严肃说话的时候会说一些轻浮的话。我承认这一点。是的，是的，你在这里有一种感觉，王尔德突然意识到机智是不够的。此时还有另一个时刻，在卡森的盘问中，那是审判的第二天，卡森宣读了昆斯伯里侯爵写给王尔德的信件。在其中一封信中，昆斯伯里把王尔德描述为一个该死的懦夫，属于罗斯伯里那种类型。罗斯伯里勋爵是自由党领袖兼首相。因此，围绕着罗斯伯里勋爵，数月来一直流传着指控和谣言，称他也喜欢同性恋。我的意思是，令人惊奇的是，多米尼克，这里与昆斯伯里侯爵还有进一步的联系，对吧？完全正确。因为昆斯伯里侯爵的长子。
Viscount Drumlinrig, had been Roseborough's private secretary. There had been allegations about the relationship between them and Lord Drumlinrig had been shot. Well, it's described as a mysterious shooting accident. A mysterious shooting accident. And people said, is this because he and Roseborough were having an affair? So at the point at which that letter is read out in open court, the prime minister, Tom, now the world is quite close to the liberal top brass. He's friends with Asquith. He's had dinner with the home secretary, Herbert Asquith, the future prime minister. At that point that that is read out in open court, suddenly this is no longer just a sort
德拉姆兰里格子爵曾是罗斯伯里的私人秘书。曾有关于他们之间关系的指控，而德拉姆兰里格勋爵被枪杀了。嗯，它被描述为一场神秘的枪击事故。一场神秘的枪击事故。人们说，这是因为他和罗斯伯里有染吗？所以在公开法庭上宣读那封信的那一刻，首相，汤姆，现在王尔德离自由党高层相当近。他是阿斯奎特的密友。他曾与内政大臣、未来的首相赫伯特·阿斯奎特共进晚餐。在公开法庭上宣读那封信的那一刻，突然之间这不再只是一种道德问题或关于名人的丑闻了。它是政治性的。政府，你知道的，立即，他们想，哦，不，因为现在我们卷入了其中，我们不能轻易放过这件事。你知道的，如果王尔德不赢，如果我们不采取行动，人们就会说你们在试图掩盖他是与首相的这个阴谋、鸡奸企业的一部分，或者当时人们会说的话，所以突然之间这现在有了这个另一个维度，所以这一切对王尔德来说都非常非常糟糕。所以在第二天还有一件事，我们的俱乐部成员彼得·克拉克向我指出了这一点，给我发了一封关于此事的电子邮件。此时。
of moral issue or a scandal about a celebrity. It's political. And the government, you know, immediately, they're like, oh, no, because now we are involved and we cannot go easy on this. You know, if Wilde doesn't win and if we don't act, people will say you were trying to cover up the fact that he's part of this conspiracy with the prime minister, sodomitical enterprise or whatever people would have said at the time so suddenly this now has this other dimension so this is all very very bad for wild so there's one other thing on day two our club member peter clark pointed this out to me sent me an email about this at this point
王尔德对他的大律师爱德华·克拉克爵士说，实际上有一件事我没有告诉你，我半夜被赶出了阿尔伯马尔酒店，而且当时有一个男孩和我在一起。如果他们发现了这件事，可能会很尴尬。正是在那个时候，他自己的大律师爱德华·克拉克爵士显然心想，哦，天哪，你知道的，他显然心想，哦，天哪。你知道的，他有。是的。你为什么不？你知道的，这不好。你显然从头到尾都在对我撒谎。所以在第三天，第二天早晨的第一件事，爱德华·克拉克爵士请求与他的当事人开会并说，我一夜没睡都在想这件事。这是一场灾难。
wild says to his barrister sir edward clark actually there is something i didn't tell you i was turned out of the albemarle hotel in the middle of the night and a boy was with me it might be awkward if they found out about it and it's at that point that his own barrister sir edward clark clearly thinks oh geez you know he Clearly thinks, oh, geez. You know, he has. Yeah. Why did you not? You know, this is not good. You have clearly been lying to me all along. So on day three, first thing that next morning, Sir Edward Clark asked for a conference with his client and says, I've been thinking overnight. This is a disaster.
你将不得不撤回诉讼。我们绝无可能获胜。可能最好的办法是让我们试着达成一项交易。克拉克去找爱德华·卡森爵士并对卡森说，看，王尔德会撤诉。你知道的，你能尽力让昆斯伯里侯爵不再追究此事吗？看起来卡森说，我会尽力，我不能保证，但卡森后来表示他并不希望王尔德因此而被追究。是的，我认为这完全合乎情理。我知道。
You are going to have to withdraw from the prosecution. There is no way we can win. Probably the best thing is for us to try to do a deal. And Clark goes to see Sir Edward Carson and says to Carson, look, Wilde will drop the case. You know, can you do your best to make the Marquess of Queensbury pursue this no further? And it seems that Carson says, I'll do my best i can't guarantee it but carson later says he did not want world pursued over this yeah i think it's absolutely plausible i know
很多历史学家现在因为爱德华·克拉克在自治危机中的角色而将他视为坏人，除非当然他们某种程度上仍然是统一主义者，是的，统一主义者，完全正确。所以爱德华·卡森得到了普遍不佳的媒体评价，但我认为他说过“当然，我们会尝试达成一笔交易”是非常合理的。我不想追究我的老同学。当然，昆斯伯里侯爵，这个喋喋不休的巨大猿猴……
a lot of historians now view sir edward carson as a baddie because of his role in the home rule crisis and unless of course they are sort of they're still unionists yeah unionists exactly so sir edward carson gets a generally bad press, but I think it's very plausible that he did say, sure, we'll try to do a deal. I don't want to pursue my old classmate. Of course, the Marquess of Greensbury, this great chattering ape...
他并不赞成这样做。这不是一个赞成做交易的人。他想摧毁王尔德，实际上也想摧毁他自己的儿子。我认为在某种程度上。我的意思是，这部分是因为他想救他的儿子，但也因为他的儿子对他太粗鲁了，昆斯伯里侯爵被他儿子的行为激怒了，以至于他决心追究到底。所以这正是发生的事情，所以王尔德撤销了诉讼，但马上提到了罗斯伯里勋爵，昆斯伯里的律师把皇家检察官。
He's not in favour of that. It's not a man in favour of doing deals. He wants to destroy Wilde and destroy his own son, actually. I think to some extent. I mean, there's partly an issue of him wanting to save his son but also his son has been so rude to him the marcus queensberry has been maddened by his son's conduct that he is determined to to pursue it so this is exactly what happens so wild drops the case but straight away mentioned lord roseberry queensbridge solicitor sends the Crown prosecutor
审判的文字记录，他们证人所说的一切的文字记录，所有的男孩。政府高层正开会进行紧急闭门会议。
a transcript of the trial, a transcript of all what their witnesses have been saying, all the boys. The government's top brass are kind of meeting in sort of emergency conclave.
内政大臣赫伯特·阿斯奎特、总检察长罗伯特·里德爵士、副总检察长弗兰克·洛克伍德爵士。所以当人们讲述奥斯卡·王尔德的审判的故事时，本能的做法就是说他是压抑、残酷、清教徒建制的受害者。但这些人认识。
Herbert Asquith, the Home Secretary, the Attorney General Sir Robert Reid, the Solicitor General Sir Frank Lockwood. So when people tell the story of the trials of Oscar Wilde, the instinctive way of doing it is to say he's the victim of a repressive, cruel, puritanical establishment. But these people know
王尔德，阿斯奎特曾邀请他共进晚餐。他们处于这样一种境地：他们认为，我们不能放过这件事。他触犯了法律。他似乎触犯了法律。我们的首相被卷了进来。多米尼克，一个耐人寻味的细节是，此时以及在随后的审判期间，罗斯伯里似乎基本上处于无法行动的状态。他似乎精神崩溃了。是的。无法解释。没有人知道是怎么回事。但这是一个耐人寻味的、极具暗示性的细节，这与审判的过程完全吻合。完全正确。所以阿斯奎特作为内政大臣。
Wilde, Asquith had had him around for dinner. And they are in a position where they think, we cannot let this go. He has broken the law. He appears to have broken the law. Our prime minister has been dragged into it. Dominic, the intriguing detail that at this point and for the duration of the trials that follow, Rosebery seems to be basically kind of out of action. He seems to have had a kind of breakdown. Yeah. Unexplained. Nobody knows what it is. But it is a kind of intriguing, very suggestive detail that this exactly maps onto the process of the trials. Exactly. And so Asquith, as Home Secretary,
他同意申请对王尔德的逮捕令。他下达命令，如果王尔德试图离开这个国家，无论在哪里找到他，都应该将其拦下。但同样，有一个非常惊人的细节，签发令状的地方法官，他查明了什么时间，那列能连接到去法国渡轮的火车什么时候出发？
he agrees to apply for a warrant for Wilde's arrest. He gives orders that if Wilde tries to leave the country, he should be stopped wherever he is found. But again, there is this kind of amazing detail that the magistrate who issues the writ, he finds at what time, when does the train leave
而他在那列火车出发后15分钟才签发了它。所以我认为，汤姆，实际上。
that will link up to the ferry that will go over to France? And he issues it for 15 minutes after that train. So I think, Tom, actually,
这会让那些自以为了解这个故事的人感到惊讶。我认为有一个论点是，实际上，远非想要狠狠打击王尔德。
and this will surprise, I imagine, a lot of people who think they know the story. I think there is an argument that actually, far from wanting to hammer wild
当权派实际上是在给他一些特殊待遇。他们希望他逃走。他们和他吃过晚饭，他们喜欢他。他们是那种去看他的戏剧并觉得它们很有趣的人。我不认为他们真的在试图拿他杀鸡儆猴。我认为这里还有一种，我认为整个罗斯伯里事件，我认为并非完全不可信，即罗斯伯里与此事有着某种程度的纠缠，也许昆斯伯里侯爵手里有 incriminating（能定罪的）证据能证明这一点。对。我认为这绝对非常合乎情理。但王尔德没有走，对吧，汤姆？
the establishment are actually giving him slightly special treatment they want him to get away they've had dinner with him they like him they're the kind of people who go to see his plays and find them funny i don't think they are actually trying to make an example of him i think also there is this kind of i think the whole roseberry thing i think is not wholly implausible that Rosebery is somehow mixed up with this and that maybe the Marx of Queensbury has incriminating evidence showing that. Right. I think that's absolutely very plausible. But Walt doesn't go, does he, Tom?
他瘫痪了。我的意思是，这太不可思议了。他在灾难面前被这种消极、这种惰性所攫取。那天晚上他本可以坐上开往法国的列车，但他没有。他仍然在，他在哪儿？他还在某个地方闲荡。他在卡多根酒店。
He's paralyzed. I mean, it's extraordinary. He's seized by this passivity, this inertia in the face of disaster. He could have taken the boat train to France that night, but he doesn't. He's still in, where is he? He's still sort of hanging around. He's at the Cadogan Hotel.
和波西在一起。是的。喝着霍克白葡萄酒和苏打水。霍克白葡萄酒和苏打水。我们是否应该通过朗读桂冠诗人约翰·贝杰曼（John Betjeman）所写的、关于那天发生的事情的记述来结束这一集？汤姆，我的意思是，你问这个问题就好像有什么可能性……
With Bosie. Yeah. Drinking hock and seltzer. Hock and seltzer. Shall we finish this episode by reading the account of what happens that day that was written by John Betjeman, the poet laureate. Tom, I mean, you asked that question as though there's some possibility that
我会拒绝。你不能拒绝，因为我都已经安排好并在随时准备着了。所以，多米尼克，我们将带着王尔德的逮捕、两次审判以及他的定罪和监禁归来。现在，汤姆，如果我不指出如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你当然可以现在就收听那个节目，那我就太失职了。如果你还不是，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册，难以置信的超值。但现在，这里是约翰·贝杰曼的伟大诗作《在卡多根酒店逮捕奥斯卡·王尔德》。一阵重击和低语声，哦，为什么他们要制造这么大的喧闹，当卧室的门豁然打开，两个便衣警察走了进来。王尔德先生，我们是来带你走的，去那重罪犯和罪犯栖息的地方。我们必须请你平静地跟我们离开，因为这里是卡多根酒店。他站起身，放下了那本黄皮书。他摇摇晃晃，眼神可怕。他擦过楼梯上的植物，被扶上外面的一辆轻便马车。
I could say no. You can't say no because I've got it all lined up and ready here. So Dominic, we will be back with Wilde's arrest, the two trials, and his conviction and imprisonment. Now Tom, it would be remiss of me not to point out that if you are a member of the Restless History
我们下次再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需收听加长节目、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。
Club, you can of course listen to that right now. And if you're not, sign up at rest is history pod.com incredible value but for now here is john betcherman's great poem the arrest of oscar wilde at the cadogan hotel a thump and a murmur of voices oh why must they make such a din as the door of the bedroom swung open, and two plain-clothes policemen come in. Mr. Wilde, we have come for to take you, where felons and criminals dwell. We must ask you to leave with us quietly, for this is the Cadogan Hotel. He rose, and he put down the yellow book. He staggered and terrible-eyed. He brushed past the plants on the staircase and was helped to a handsome outside.
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一泼秀场八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加长节目和抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
We'll see you next time. Goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点八家花边。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
即 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。